you know what I hate about online anime
discourse you could be writing high off
the back of watching your favorite show
you could be expressing why you love it
so much and inevitably you'll get
someone chiming in with a comment like
chill out it's not that deep Bro like
there are most certainly ways of
overintellectualizing our favorite
stories and hey if your relationship
with a movie ends with the credits then
more power to you but I think the idea
that there's nothing more to discuss
Beyond General momentto moment content
is a real disservice to well all of
fiction really if all that mattered were
those plot beats then I'm sure a work
like one piece wouldn't be held up as a
once in a generation type story let
alone one its fans painstakingly dissect
take the sport of boxing for example
anyone can jump in for big fights and
have a great time but those that follow
the buildup of the fights the psychology
of the fighters and the histories
between them will no doubt go in with
greater anticipation but will also gain
a greater deal of meaning from the
actual event itself and well the way in
which context and subtext informs events
in real life is a pivotal function when
applied to fiction so I guess what I'm
saying is it actually is that deep Bro
and that has been my motivation behind
delivering this series of video essays
beginning right here with this one a
series where I explore how the key
players of One Piece function why they
are amazing and through doing so gain a
deeper appreciation for a od's story and
where better to start than with a
character many people love but some find
one-dimensional and I think is genius I
am of course talking
[Music]
about
Luffy's pronounced smile and boundless
optimism conceals a much lonelier
character one filled with love and
ambition yes but also one that deeply
desires companionship this need early on
speaks to a childhood we won't see for
quite some time but the seeds are all
there this is all to say that while
Luffy himself is an interesting
character where he shines best is
through those he interacts with in John
Troy's book the anatomy of story he
mentions that a common misconception
about main characters is that they
themselves are the reason the story is
interesting now he's certainly not
suggesting Luffy isn't interesting what
trbi means here is that in isolation a
character is made up of many different
attitudes opinions and backstories but
it's how those aspects of their
personality inform their interactions
with the world and its characters that
make them interesting in other words or
to put it more simply our interest in
them is born worn from how our main
character interacts with those around
them for example Tony Soprano is a huge
personality but it's how he navigates
the world and speaks to people that
brings all of the qualities we love and
hate about him to the surface
highlighting and defining what makes him
so iconic and while Tony isn't a hero
the same applies to heroic stories like
one piece quote the single biggest
mistake writers make when creating
characters is that they think of the
hero and all other characters as separ
seate individuals their hero is alone in
a vacuum unconnected to others the
result is not only a weak hero but also
cardboard opponents and minor characters
who are even weaker in other words your
hero can only be seen or felt as
righteous by contrasting him or her to
the Allies that have their backs or the
villains slinking around each and every
corner and if we keep that in mind it
becomes apparent that Oda has designed
Luffy from the ground up to be a
character that necess necessitates great
writing fundamentals you've no doubt
heard this piece of writing advice
before it's everywhere show don't tell
while not a hard rule in of itself it's
certainly a valuable piece of advice to
heat if all your hero does is talk about
how great of a person he is ironically
you'll not only fail to convince your
audience of his virtue but through doing
so you'll unconsciously demonstrate how
he's in fact a narcissist So to avoid
this Robert mcke says in his book story
quote true character can only be
expressed through choice in dilemma how
the person chooses to act under pressure
is who he is the greater the pressure
the truer and deeper the choice to
character in other words if you place
your character in high pressure
situation the decisions they make in
those moments matter far more and mean
far more to us reading along than
whatever they could try to convince us
of by yammering at our faces it's like
real life words are cheap people can lie
and what what's genius about Luffy's
design is how he engages with the world
he inhabits how he forces those
situations to take Center Stage
naturally because of who he
is Kobe is one of the earliest
characters introduced in one piece and
Oda uses him as a sort of audience POV
character a litmus test of Luffy's
qualities he comes to understand that
Luffy is a righteous person the same way
we at home do at least if you're
watching the anime once Luffy reveals
himself to Kobe as a stowaway Kobe is
put in a very difficult circumstance
he's low on the totem pole within his
pirate crew and he's got an obligation
to reveal Luffy to a superior but he
doesn't now this doesn't stop lady
alvita later on from discovering Luffy
and once she does she begins verbally
disparaging and degrading the young Kobe
who's now visibly terrified after being
discovered and this all takes place in
front of Luffy however like we will see
with practically every single instance
Luffy encounters potential new crew
members Luffy doesn't take what others
say very seriously he looks at their
actions and for Kobe he saw how scared
he was how much he stands to lose by not
ratting him out and has learned his
dream he knows that nothing lady alv
Bellows can possibly be true about Kobe
because Luffy has already seen Kobe
respond to a difficult situation by
making the choice that was right for him
free from the shackles of his own mental
and physical prison Luffy was able to
see what and who Kobe truly is and this
is powerful because we at home get to
experience that too we get to appreciate
Kobe as a character now all the more
because we too have seen him perform in
this high stake situation and this
pattern is expanded upon with
practically every Straw Hat pirate for
instance when Kobe someone who Luffy now
trusts warns him about how dangerous
Zoro is Luffy remains consistent words
are cheap he knows Kobe doesn't have
firsthand experience and he knows what
others have said about himself and Kobe
maybe they're wrong too about Zoro and
through this approach Luffy Waits For a
Moment of character Revelation he waits
for Oda to write a scene that
demonstrates zoro's true
nature
[Applause]
this is what makes Luffy such a
mechanically useful character in The
Narrative like the rule of thumb he
demands to be shown who people are
instead of being told who they are it's
a simple but geniously elegant character
mechanic and nowhere is that more true
than in arlong park for many this is the
first moment one piece quote gets good
and while I don't agree with that
statement as I thought it was great from
the start this is the AR where Oda
really places this trait of Luffy's
front and center for all of us to enjoy
and as a result facilitates one of the
most timeless story experiences I've
ever had while reading manga a series of
deceptions are made by Nami who's fooled
her whole town into hating her but not
Luffy who Bears witness to another
emphatic action from Nami stabbing her
own shoulder where the symbol of her
enslavement resides a surface level
observation of Nami would suggest she's
part of arlong's crew but the actions
taken here shows that there's far more
to this character both literally and
metaphorically reinforcing this
principle that actions speak more than
words do no matter what anyone on the
island says about Nami no matter what
she says to Luffy's face her actions
tell a very different story a story of a
young girl with the weight of the world
on her shoulders now crushing her to her
knees Moving Mountains to push away
those she loves in order to protect them
and in that moment and in that emotional
Crescendo between Luffy and Nami she
Cycles through all of her defense
mechanisms right before his eyes she
physically throws dust at him verbally
berates him and lies further but as soon
as she realizes that he knows who she
really is she breaks down in front of
him pleading for help this same
Narrative Approach can be seen with his
recruitment of Usopp Robin and a host of
others too every one of the straw hats
is a lost toy cast aside in one shape or
form ignoring their dreams for one
reason or another Luffy despite being a
boisterous and upbeat character
demonstrates moments of quiet
contemplation and observation as every
single one of the straw hat Pirates
proves themselves either when they think
no one is looking or when they are under
serious pressure to act this is taken to
an extreme on HK Island there are a host
of elements to discuss when analyzing
the katakuri fight and one can certainly
point to a number of of instances in
this conflict where Luffy allows
katakuri to discover more about himself
but it's his hunger strike with Sanji
following their bout that left me
utterly speechless as a
reader this is of course sanji's Arc so
to speak and there's plenty of time to
talk about him in another video but with
regards to Luffy's involvement this is
by far the most he's been pushed away by
a member of his team and this push from
Sanji is carried out through action he
physically assaults Luffy and tears down
his character much like nami's behavior
in arlong park this is all in the name
of protecting him from the monsters in
his closet Luffy sees this recognizes
what's happening and understands that
Sanji needs to find his own way back to
him and where he waited for Nami in
arlong park Luffy takes this up a notch
here reserving himself to a hunger
strike until his return however while I
have explored this quality Luffy brings
to the likes of the straw head crew this
altercation with Sanji as well as his
runin and subsequent conflict with Usopp
in water 7 speaks to another interesting
area Oda explores with great results and
I think this element of Luffy's
character has offered my three favorite
moments in the entire series for me the
leadup two and subsequent eruption of
Uso versus Luffy Remains the single most
compelling sequence of character
exchanges I've ever come across this is
taking into stories like berserk and
every film I've seen since I was a child
to say that this scene captures magic in
a bottle would be an understatement and
it has everything to do with a narrative
technique called structural opposition
of Desire dramatic situations are made
most compelling when conflict exist as a
structural opposition of goals now that
is some weird word spaghetti but put
simply it means that if one character
gets what they want the other character
can't while it's true that Luffy's goal
is to become king of the Pirates and to
find the one piece Oda took the seeds
planted in those early chapters and
built on them over time throughout
childhood flashbacks Luffy's upbeat and
ambitious nature is underpinned by
abject loneliness a desire for
companionship becomes crystal clear and
it's not hard to see why his mom is
absent his father has left Shanks his
Hero has left he was led to believe one
of his sworn Brothers was dead and the
other like everyone else left him alone
to embark on his own adventure and so
although that initial naivity may have
been resolved in chapter 1 Luffy
embarked on his journey into the East
blue harboring a flaw that would not
rear its head until much much
later Luffy is surprisingly ill equipped
when it comes to emotional conflict with
his crew and in being forced to deal
with it here this goal of persistent
companionship bubbles up to the surface
as Usopp lets forth a devastating
Outburst brought on by insecurity Luffy
is put in a position wholly new to him
rather than being an observer of tough
decision- making like he did with nami
and Zoro he becomes a participant he's
forced to choose between his two goals
he doesn't want to break up his family
but in order to be the captain the rest
of his crew deserves he must this is why
I love this scene for the first time in
the series Luffy is offered a dma that
speaks to his deepest desires and forces
him to choose and through doing so
brings out the very best of his
Supporting
[Music]
Cast for me my favorite part of One
Piece has never been the fights or the
Grand Adventure or even the colorful
locasion we all get to explore and enjoy
all of those offer a tremendous amount
to appreciate but nothing compares to
the dynamic Luffy has with his crew
within one piece the story itself isn't
so much the story of Luffy alone but
instead his relationship with his crew
members and the enemies he faces think
about it Luffy's ultimate goal is to
become the king of the Pirates to find
the fabled one piece treasure he's
unabashedly himself loud in your face
and will literally move Heaven and Earth
for his friends in spite of his
boisterousness he feels like a righteous
and well-intentioned character that
deeply cares for his friends but he only
feels as righteous as he does because of
the characters that don't align with
these beliefs within the story arlong
was cruel vengeful and dishonest
crocodile was cruel too and deeply
manipulative this even extends to the
world government or emu these are
characters that are totally antithetical
to what Luffy has been designed to be
where Luffy loudly declares his desires
and goals U hides and operates in the
shadows where Luffy will die for his
team and carry the Lion Share of the
burden when necessary those in power
within the world of One Piece not only
Force others to enact their bidding but
also tear those less powerful than
themselves down further those are the
components that make Luffy stand out and
it works both ways those aformentioned
villains feel all the more monstrous
when put up against Luffy himself if you
plop Luffy into another story he might
still feel like a fun character but
suddenly he's a lot less interesting
this is because the world of of One
Piece has been defined and designed
around highlighting all of Luffy's
strengths and weaknesses to this end his
crewm mat shine a light on his best
qualities and in some instances expose
his weaknesses painful as they are to
see but for me insight into weakness is
far more effective than any highlight of
strength or to put it another way great
characters are often defined by who they
are not and what they cannot
do
I've often spoken about how I love Goku
and Luffy in the same breath but what
they offer mechanically and emotionally
within the respective stories is vastly
different I think part of Goku's appeal
for me is how much emotional space there
is between him and most every other
character heck even the audience really
he doesn't look at situations very often
the same way many others do there is an
emotional disconnect that creates this
almost superhuman Presence at times
where he acts as this entity descending
from on high to save the day through
circumstance he values his friends their
safety and all the rest of it but that
often takes a back seed to his desire to
satiate this need for combat a desire
that is almost impossible for us to
fully rationalize whereas Luffy as made
evident numerous times throughout his
journey is specifically driven by his
desire to protect his friends to protect
their dreams to protect their treasure
through his journey to Gyer crew Luffy
in pursuit of his own treasure has
created this secondary treasure one I do
not think he would give up to achieve
his primary goal when Goku lost Krillin
on Namek to Frieza he snapped into a
violent rage it was no longer about
saving his friends or being the
strongest he can be for that instant it
was just rage and Vengeance when Luffy
lost his crew in Sai one by one they
were taken away from him and after each
and every one was taken Luffy became
more and more desperate and incensed
until they were all gone and what
happened then he collapses to the ground
with nothing left this is a remarkably
special moment in this series and it is
such because it's the first time we've
seen what Luffy looks like in total
despair every Beacon of Hope in the
series now there is none he's lost his
crew he's lost his friends his family
he's lost his treasure each and every
time you compare a character to the hero
unconsciously you're forced to
distinguish and Define the hero in new
ways but what I love about this scene
and the arc that precedes It Isn't So
Much what other characters can do for
Luffy but instead what he as a character
does to enhance and highlight The
Supporting Cast without any of them
being present in the scene what follow
Saudi is perhaps the single best way Oda
could have ever employed this writing
principle and it's all contained in what
I think is one of the most critically
underrated arcs the series has seen
Amazon
lily as I mentioned earlier a large part
of what defines a character especially a
main character are the choices they make
and the differences that come about
thanks to the comparisons between them
and other characters normally this
technique is used to serve the main
character and the main villain of a
given area or segment but what what
makes this segment of Amazon Lily so
impressive to me is that without anyone
other than Luffy himself he raises his
own stock the villains of this Arc stock
and without anyone else to share the
screen or page with he improves our
appreciation and consideration of the
straw hat Pirates just by existing that
is incredible design and I don't know if
I've ever seen any other character do
that and how does Oda achieve this
simply by allowing Luffy to be Luffy
alone in Amazon Lily he falls sick
reminding us of Chopper usefulness he
becomes hungry reminding us of how
important Sanji is to him he gets lost
informing us on how important nami's
navigation is he's alone without backup
showing us how important his crew is and
most specifically Zoro it intentionally
goes on like this until he runs into a
situation with boa hanock and her crew
where again simply by Lu marching to the
beat of his own drum he enhances her
appreciation of him and emphasizes the
antagonist defining
characteristics normally when I'm
reading a story I can appreciate the
writing based on what I see happening
where I see the story going and how I
can see the author deciding to get there
but when we arrived at Amazon Lily I've
never been so taken aback and impressed
by a Shonen story like this writers like
air Oda want us to resonate with their
tales on a deep and personal level to
get lost in them and through doing so
gain deeper insight into our own
feelings and emotions this is made
evident through the countless flashbacks
he incorporates and his dedication to
establishing each and every character
the crew interacts with little their
role might be in oda's one piece there
are no vapid characters everything is
deliberate everything has life sometimes
the art of of Storytelling is best
delivered when you don't notice the
subtle techniques and themes that reside
underneath the surface and far be it for
me to deny anyone the wonderful
experience it must be to get sucked away
into a world to enjoy it how you want to
and if all you get from Luffy's
character is the amusement of a funny
stretchy rubber man who hits the bad
guys hard and loves food then so be it
there's certainly value in that form of
escapism but it's important to realize
that that is not all there is to one
piece and that's okay it is precisely
why Aira Oda is a once in a lifetime
Storyteller in his immersive and
colorful world where people can wield
the power of supernatural beings bending
elements and people to their will
through magic and political influence
when all of that is present in your
story and your most powerful moments can
still be a kid placing a hat on a young
girl's head or a moment of utter despair
when one falls to his knees then that is
when you know you dealing with something
truly special something with artistic
substance and in the case of Monkey D
Luffy an unmistakably genius
character if you want to make sure you
see my coverage of the other straw head
pirates in this video series be sure to
subscribe and ring the bell icon or if
you want to see early cuts of these
videos before they're posted to YouTube
you can support us on patreon the link
is in the description once again thank
you all so much for watching guys and we
will see you in the next
[Music]
video